hello welcome back to the lobby
GameSpot's for video game talk show
every Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific right
here on GameSpot calm or twitch.tv
forward slash GameSpot or if you're
watching this on demand on GameSpot our
YouTube and for the very first time if
you're listening to this on your podcast
machines
wherever you are you know on a commute
you're on the toilet you're on the
toilet on a commute and we finally have
a podcast version of the lobby it should
be up if you're watching is live it'll
be like a couple of hours from now buh
yeah you could finally subscribe and
listen to us in your earholes we wanted
to make sure we sounded the part before
we did it so thanks for your patience we
will send the part and also look the
part she got a brand new say hey look at
it we got a caption stuff here for when
we're doing our Friday live show thingy
we got all this we've got the sweet sory
poster shout out to goopes you write
GameSpot viewer and fine who gave us
these sweet Nuka Cola bottles and we
stuck some lights under them very pretty
sure that's Josh's giant model ship yes
the SS Pikmin back here as well it's so
great yes I believe he even acquired
that ship through nefarious means so we
thought why not someone at listeners
know that that has been in the office
for many months so Thank You Josh really
appreciate it and thank you Scott for
joining us tonight I'm thrilled to be
here on the inaugural episode for this
set this lovely new set yeah and the new
format everything it's very cool it's
very nice in here I just wanna live in
here appreciate it's like the best
living room it's really nice yeah it
doesn't get too hot we haven't tested I
yet they could get a hot it's hot as
balls I mean I I'm here make you want to
vomit here it does look nice in here and
the lighting and everything came out
really good so thank you for joining us
thanks for having me yeah you played a
bunch of games you've all been playing a
bunch of games we got all the GameSpot
editors coming in who've all played a
bunch of games so we're gonna get them
in to talk about them we've a bumper
show today and we're gonna talk about
Titan fool titanfall 2 sorry if it
should have a campaign Fire Emblem fates
we have really really already accessed
that ice we're gonna have folks
to talk about what they've been playing
what they think of it and it's a most of
it's not even under embargo so I should
be fun at darkest dungeon as well Mary
you're gonna talk to us about that one
Mike my Hardy but first of all fire
watch local developers camposanto yes
finally released their inaugural game
anticipated very much so it's been it
seems have been previewed at a bunch of
events for years and years we finally
got to play it Scott you were reviewed
it said yes 10 on GameSpot calm yes good
but not great basically yeah there are
certain parts of the game that are like
a 9 or a 10 that is just something I've
never seen a game support that are
beautifully executed just the writing
and and really the characters are unlike
anything that I've ever played and
really kind of only directing the
relationship between the two main
characters is something you could kind
of only do in a game and having the
control and the ability to sort of shape
this dynamic and to read this really
thoughtful insight into the way that a
meaningful relationship is formed is
really it's just special it really is
unfortunately not all over the game is
quite as special as that relationship
and it kind of stumbles in certain ways
and so yeah ultimately it landed at a
seven I feel like that score suggests
like it's okay when really it's like no
there are things it does a lot of stuff
really good there are things that I'm so
good it just kind of balances out and
ends up being a seven in the end so
hopefully people who are interested so
give it a chance because I really did
enjoy a great deal yeah seems super
unique like I guess that we have Steve
gainer in a couple of weeks ago we were
talking about the rise of the walking
simulator and why not sure this seems
like it's it's that it be a bit
reductive to say it's it's like gone
home but it's it's quite linear is all
right Mary you completed it last night
right yeah I just finished it and I
would I would actually compare it very
much to gone yeah it's very in the sense
that you you know this is a it's got a
destination
you can't deviate too much from it
you're going to get to an end result but
you know the way you experience your
character and the way you interpret
other characters is up to you and so
it's about taking the narration the
narrative and in deciding what kind of
person you are who are you playing
because you're making choices right like
does the sort of the demo we've seen a
lot of which is the you know you come up
with the girls in the the pond and do
you like throw their stereo in the pond
or do you just shout at them or do you
just turn it off does those
decisions do they make meaningful
impacts marry not that I found and I
think that's you know we're being I'm
being a little vague on purpose yes
because this is a short game and I don't
want to ruin it for anyone but as vague
as I can say I felt that most of my
decisions didn't really change anything
and that can maybe upset people but then
you can take a step back and reflect on
it and realize that the things that you
take away with our you know the person
you played as and the people that you
talked to and what that meant to you and
that like Scott said it's it's very
powerful like the relationship and a
path to tremendous writing and really
good acting therefore Milan seduces
little inflections in the way lines are
deliver you can really like read a lot
into the way things are said just the
tone and like just these subtleties in
the way lines are delivered is really
really extremely story-driven so right
even you know talking about it broadly
almost feels like a spoiler like in the
review I talked about how I felt like
the central mystery doesn't totally pay
off and even that to me almost feels
like a spoiler in a way right even
though that's not specific at all but
but I know what you mean any any when
any game this small and he's sort of not
not in any direction as a giveaway so
let's yeah let's maybe reel it back from
the story stuff you guys have explained
it very well let's talk about this stuff
we don't mind a bit spoiling a technical
issues so I asked Mary in a second she's
fresh off the boat when it comes to this
you played it last week and you had some
problems on PC less so on No on ps4
correct less so on PC and Joshua as well
just saw one of our video editors that
also played the game and also
experienced the same problems that I had
I mean like I described it in the review
persistent minor but persistence and the
other thing that's really gonna break
the game for you but stuff that is like
a little annoying specifically on ps4
the one problem that persisted through
the entire game was any time we hit like
a new section of the map or the game was
auto-saving
you would notice a note there was a
noticeable framerate stutter alright so
the game would kind of chug for about a
second and then things would be fine but
in a game that's all about emergent
emergent and atmosphere yeah it kind of
takes you have the experience but every
couple minutes it's like okay there's
the load icon it's
okay so it would have been really nice
if that hadn't been the case doesn't
happen nearly as often on PC still
happens sometimes in PC kind of has its
own issues yeah also had a couple
crashes I mean Josh
Josh's game crashed three times I guess
a mine crashed twice so I mean again
it's not you know something to the world
I don't really lose much progress but
yeah it's just something something worth
noting if you're if you're getting into
the game and hopefully Mary had a better
chance and I did okay didn't ruinous but
it was just worth noting mmm I played it
on PC zero crashes and maybe like a few
starters that didn't really bother me
and which is really good for my
experience because you're right it's
incredibly immersive and it's so
beautiful and there are these long
stretches where you're just walking
through the woods and just fine and it's
so beautiful it's huge part of it right
is that you're just you're just walking
through the woods thinking about stuff
you know
yeah feelings and thinking thoughts and
slowly and surely music builds in the
background it comes up thinking music
you know and so you're just walking in
the woods thinking about your life it's
like I'm playing the long dark and then
the witness came out I feel like walking
through what beautiful woods is like the
the way of 2016 already you game so far
for sure yeah all right let's get right
down to it obviously you guys the
reviews on the side both of you seem to
have enjoyed it quite a lot and is this
a game do you think people should pick
up straight away it's 1999 normally on
steam at $17.99 at the moment 10% off
launch week proper launch window sale
yeah Mary what did you think was it was
it worth the time how much time did you
spend on it and I actually burned
through it yeah burned through it it's
number two on the show
the fire emblem coming up next so our
puns are so hot hot show oh my god
really really sorry
anyway I burned through it in like three
and a half four hours which is really
quick okay but I really did enjoy those
hours I don't think this game is for
everyone and I say that because you said
this in your review you know if you are
looking for puzzles and you know
QuickTime events or gameplay mechanics
that you learn and then
manipulate this game doesn't have any of
that you should go into this game
understanding what it is this game is a
narrative story driven experience that
you walk through you'll never you know
be tested or tried in terms of gameplay
it's strictly just about you playing
this dude and some stuff happens to them
and you decide how he handles it it's
like yeah whether he's angry it is it is
beautiful and so I do want to come on a
compliment like how gorgeous it is
it's very thought-provoking and
interesting but it's not for everyone
and and you know what that's have
appropriate expectations that's right if
you like those types of games you know
if you like everybody's gone to the
rapture be ready for that kind of
experience yeah I mean even if you
played a bunch of telltale adventure
games this game doesn't even have the
QuickTime events you would normally find
in those games yeah yeah it really is a
very deliberately paced you know kind of
a slow burn sorry
no again I can't hold my going and even
though I mean there's actually a really
interesting conversation you could have
about player agency in this game and how
much of an impact you have but then
you're really getting into spoiler
territory so I'll just say that okay I
took a little more time with it my first
playthrough lasted about seven hours
because I really just wandered through
and enjoyed the world and soaked
everything in and I feel like I really
got a lot out of it even though the
central mystery again doesn't really
build up I think that the process of
building the relationship between Henry
Lee Henry and Delilah the two main
characters in the game it was again just
something I've never really experienced
anywhere else and in a game or anywhere
and it was truly beautiful it's really
unique and for me that makes it
absolutely worthwhile and I'm also you
know generally inclined to be like hey
this is a passion project this was you
know a smaller team and doing something
really cool and right I think that's in
my mind commendable I'm you know I'm not
gonna tell it like rush out and buy it
right now but I mean as far as things
you can spend your money on it seems
like a pretty good one to me yeah a lot
of reasons recommend it's comfortable
thank you so much for coming in absolute
town gamespot.com folks can go read that
review yes I wish you I'd watch it is
why we got a woman to reveal we got a
one minute review on Facebook we didn't
want to do the full full review we
normally do we barely talked about it
for 10 minutes without spoiling yes
exactly it's so
you couldn't show much for that game
without spoiling everything so we didn't
do a four of you just the one minute but
it's on Facebook so go watch that and
it's also spoiler free completely clean
go for it
alright Scott thanks so much Mary you
stick around because we're gonna talk
about darkest dungeon in a second Mike
my heart he's coming in to talk about
that bad boy Scott thank you so much you
get it
banging your knee I'll do my best do
anything we got a bunch of people coming
on the show today
an x-ray Korea and Peter brand they got
to be on later on as well because
they've played Fire Emblem fates Aaron
Sam's gonna be on later we're gonna have
real chin wag about titanfall to whether
or not it needs a campaign and II try
not to kill Scott on the way out awesome
I could we got a shout-out for Andy's
kneepads by the way I feel like that is
something that requires - no no no look
at a professional no that's not is that
the shot I don't know and for the
podcast version there are things that go
over his knees a pretty oculus version
sorry for his shot there which probably
just made you all get very sick doing
God's work Andy also he's wearing orange
oh God collusion we almost had a poster
as well but it just didn't turn up no
wasn't you want a patch on you only wear
things from sorry folks in the twitch
chat as well and I am looking at your
questions I've got a bunch queued up as
well we're gonna get them on the show
that one I wanted to stay away from
questions because they were all asking
about the story but yeah if you have any
questions about darkest dungeon send
them in right now alright
darkest dungeon it earned a bunch of
money four times its Kickstarter goal
feels like years ago at this stage came
ours already accessed last year I
remember yourself and Alexa to the video
stream of it was about one year ago yeah
so now it's like officially a yes and
Mike you haven't reviewed it for
GameSpot we have one of our freelancers
yeah Daniel Stark okay cool it's up
today it's all for this morning oh
really yeah awesome yeah but you've been
playing it as well recently I had yeah
first of all your thoughts how does it
play did you play at all during its
already access release very like only a
little bit probably like a few hours at
most
I know Maryanne Alexa like we just
mentioned played more than I
so I was curious I kept asking him about
it because I wanted to play it but yeah
we had the review went up is 9 out of 10
like the problems Daniel had were
they're very much in line with mine it's
very good all around except you know
like it can be overwhelming as far as
the menus go and it's kind of like
obtuse in that sense but yeah the game's
great it's really good for folks who
don't know much about this game Mary I'm
not sure if you played recently again
yeah the affliction system you talked a
little bit about that that's the whole
thing were people basically in this game
kind of are constantly on the edge you
going crazy right that's right it's kind
of an additional gambling system of
death where you you know it's a
turn-based RPG you're just kind of
dungeon crawling you could consider it a
roguelike in the sense that everything
is generated and it's perma death and
you know random things can happen but
the affliction system is this additional
element it kind of gives it a bit more
unique sense that you every character
that's in these dungeons can have
afflictions happen to them whether that
be fear or the opposite maybe they
become really rabid or cold and they
just think they're the best and they're
just like really into themselves and all
of a sudden they will do things without
you telling them to do that look they
will they will switch what whether
they're first or last in turn they will
refuse to do what you tell them they'll
attack randomly without without you
doing anything I saw one where there was
somebody who was so close to death that
she just refused to take medical
assistance okay I'm dead I'm going to
die anyway I hope us or masochistic is
another characteristic though just
they'll like get in front of other
people who are getting attacked because
they just really need punishment yeah
for like one reason either a lot of murk
they characterize a lot of them some
there's actually a few that are like
anti beasts so if you have some werewolf
in your party rapes yes someone someone
who I forget the like-like-like can
throw phobe or something I don't know
they hate werewolf so like Enya you try
to bring them in the same party they'll
be like I'm not going near that foul
creature yet yeah and then the let's say
that because they get this affliction
and they I don't know they act out of
turn and then they actually die from it
the wolf will feel bad really
okay because he because of who he is
he's causing people in his party to die
and to feel guilty about it and he'll
feel like [ __ ] and he won't want to go
out so you after these really aggressive
and they're all terrible nothing good
happens in this game I just want you
guys to know like the very first thing
that happens to Neelix is we read a book
and it was a it was a bad book and it
scares the [ __ ] out of our person yeah
made him scared for the whole turn so
they come back and they are miserable or
they feel terrible and it's your job to
treat them to the best of your ability
whether that be take them to a brothel
or you know to a bar oh yeah let them
relax it's a huge and there's a lot of
realistic elements to this game that
after you've gone through some [ __ ] you
got to figure out what's the best way to
let them cope whether that be through
religion or booze or yeah some of them
will be like atheist so you can't have
them pray okay because that's not gonna
do anything to them and then some are
like alcoholics so you shouldn't put
them in the bar right and yeah so that's
there's nothing at no point during the
like dozen or so hours I played this
game that I feel in control until later
until later you start to have like level
8 and higher heroes because they take a
while to rank up you know either
it's pretty persistent but later on you
actually start to have these good
characters but you still kind of accept
that like bad shits gonna happen I think
it's meant to be a hard game yeah yeah
it's like it's not it's like Dark Souls
it's not just like unfair I
intentionally is meant to be difficult
ya know I would arcs right right no no
no right I would it's very much I don't
like a lot of it is not you're kind of
just okay that's unfair but that's what
I got into yeah yeah
so it's Sharky says it in his review
really well which is that it's almost
become cliche to say that it's Dark
Souls s so many people freaking say that
when it comes to a game being difficult
but this game truly deserves the nod
because it's difficult in the sense that
although it is going to throw a lot at
you you have everything in your ability
to
to help prevent these measures think of
it like and strike you said this is well
really well like a like a poker you
don't know what card is gonna be dealt
but if you're a good player you're
eventually going to win so this game is
teaching you to become a good player
you're going to lose again and again and
again and it's gonna consistently you
know sometimes you're gonna have a bad
roll of the dice and you're gonna read a
bad book yeah but if you're good you
should have a plan ready for when that
happened yeah that's a really fair point
it is like crazy how like I even said it
myself I said it's like a Dark Souls
games like difficult yeah but you were
saying before that there's like there is
this sort of weird little Renaissance of
difficult difficult games I guess is the
way to say it was a Jake Solomon you
were talking to him yeah I was talking
to Jake Solomon like lead designer
creative director over at for access on
XCOM and Garth DeAngelis the producer
and we were talking about how just this
year with between Tharsis the witness I
just come to darkest dungeon and the
Dark Souls 3 is coming out soon but this
is like the biggest clump of really
difficult games we've had and I think we
all have recognized because a lot of
people around the office have been
saying like I don't remember the last
time I played a game where I like felt
comfortable but here's like the mass
Marcus success of games like Call of
Duty like games that you know aren't
they're challenging that it's like an
easy ramp for you like games like not to
constantly going on to my first-person
games but the games like this and the
games I want you to play but like have
that like difficulty ramp that's quite
it's difficult it's forgiving yeah it's
like allowing you to like level up or
whatever like these are games that force
difficult questions on you right yeah
then you you know you have the complete
opposite which you know like this is a
stigma that's been attached to Nintendo
with a lot of stuff is that they
handhold I mean right it's not sure with
everything but yeah I know they like I
had mentioned it when I was playing the
witness a lot it felt like the first
game in a while that actually just like
respected my intelligence not that other
games weren't but to such an extent that
it like it has confidence that you can
really figure out it knows you're a
smart person that kind of rewards you
for you know it rewards you for playing
and agreeing with it I guess and like a
weird sense and it's nice to have that
refreshing yeah must be difficult to
make games like that yeah especially
like looking at something like the
witness and this game we seem to have a
lot going on where you really have to
like trust
that you have to get the player to trust
you that the game isn't broken then it's
not like it's you it's not the game yeah
and the witness is such a good example
of a difficulty curve in a game because
although there are puzzles in there that
are insane and they will absolutely rock
you there's nothing there's no stone
left unturned that Jonathan Blow didn't
specifically intend for it to be in that
game and you'll know that moment because
when you do solve it you'll go oh I'm an
idiot it was there the whole time if I
would have looked around there are clues
everywhere and that happens in a lot of
games if you I mean give them some
credit you know a lot of this is player
you know you got to improve your own
skills to really understand when you get
that enlightenment it's such a good
feeling anyway thanks comes who was a
lot like down the office because there
was some folks who because ex-cons whose
harder next come one yeah so then you're
playing X I'm 2 and being like I'm not
so sure if this is like as finely tuned
as ex-con 1 it is you just gotta have to
change your mentality when you're going
into it yeah I think it shows and that
the tutorial gives you the fundamentals
that people played enemy Unknown enemy
within should have a grasp of and I'm
sure like hardcore veterans of enemy
Unknown maybe bumped up the difficulty
right away I played a lot but I hadn't
played in a while so I played in default
and after the tutorial was immediately
clear how many layers I wasn't shown
right at the beginning and I think it
shows confidence that you know these are
smart people they can figure it out in
their own I think they're they know that
this the fail you're supposed to be
meaningful and you're supposed to fail
yeah and I think that's kind of like a
really cool idea it's it's been used
before but it's just like like Garth and
Jake had been saying when I was
interviewing them about ex-con - it's
kind of a lot more games or I think are
willing to do that right now they want
to give you the responsibility and with
that comes the reward you know if that's
right if it says that this shot has a
95% chance to hit and it doesn't do you
blame the game and say well my stupid
shooter got that 5% or do you
acknowledge that you should be prepared
for the chance that it might not hit
it's giving you that power and that
responsibility and that's a great thing
so final thoughts on darkest dungeon and
then I kind of swiveled you guys away
from that for a little bit
9 out of 10 it's $24.99 on Steam if
people haven't played it
recommend they pick it up definitely
yeah if you're in the mood for a
difficult game but like we were just
saying one that kind of has confidence
you're gonna figure it out go for it
it's it's really good 9 out of 10
definitely very deserving more based off
me absolutely I couldn't recommend it
enough it is gut wrenching but it's it's
absolutely a well deserved score it's a
good game and you should pick it up and
you feel like I don't know what else it
is it's a Kickstarter game that [ __ ]
came out and was good for them was a
second one ever yeah there's so many
that people are down on or like that did
okay but just didn't like cuz when you
invest already on a game like that I
feel like your expectation gets like
super high
like I like Double Fine adventure what
it ended up becoming broken age but like
I know a lot of people aren't like super
super hot on had ended up great like
mighty number 9 is a complete disaster
at this stage yeah no I was funny
loading up darkest dungeon it's just you
I almost forget that it was a kickstart
what are the first yeah it was I think
was the biggest before broken age
probably er yeah I think I think it was
what I got four times the funding and it
it has the Kickstarter logo that's the
first thing you see when you look at the
game of the title screen right next
anyway yeah and early access and yeah
they've been part of all of these weird
negative words actually maybe they'll be
the very responsible for the rise and
the inevitable the kind of Kickstarter
because of those problems that they have
but then you have good things too
like exploding kittens sure do really
well and how to full boyfriend plushies
that's thanks so much for coming in
there talking to us we're gonna rotate
out and get Alexa ray Correa and Peter
Brown in God we doing a lot of swapping
today thanks so much for coming on Mary
yeah sup guys
how you doing Fire Emblem thanks so much
to everyone who's in the the chat most
of the questions coming in are mostly
saying this show looks sick shout-out to
mr. Baumann and mr. Talia mr. Shaw and
gurke of course hey what's up hi hey I'm
great how are you how are you LexA hey
welcome to the show do you like our
place this is awesome isn't it pretty
it's moody it's nice and comfortable is
it Moody
while the mood would you give it comfy
comfortable weekend mood weekend isn't
the mood Peter [ __ ] yeah weekend's a
time weekend can be this guy's right
we're living no I pay someone in China
to read for me right you're confused yes
that's yeah it's the future of game
journalism actually while we're talking
about game journalism it would be a
little [ __ ] we should probably say
something about poor game trailers
yesterday yeah shut down yeah
those poor guys after 13 years all the
folks over there I guess called Boston
Brandon Jones Daniel Bloodworth and all
that that big crew I thought so go ahead
to you guys hope you land on your feet
or find a new adventure but yeah 13
years around and I just feel like that
like that the whole game journalism
landscape is just totally different to
what it was like even five or six years
ago it is I think it's tough to because
they were sold to accompany I think yeah
I yeah two years ago yeah and like in
the history of you know websites or
companies like ours like when that
happens there's always layoffs
associated with you can look back and
see it in so many different websites but
it's it's a little insane to me that
they just totally shut it down yeah yeah
feel so bad for those dudes yeah but you
know they seem all like nice people
already time I run into them they were
cool so I think based in Los Angeles I
think I'm not sure I would believe it
down there yeah whenever we run into
them yeah yeah so I've shoutouts to
GameTrailers thanks for 13 years of
awesome entertainment and yeah sorry for
that and best of luck in the next couple
of weeks and once and if you're watching
this and you need folks who do awesome
video or writing there's a bunch of
really really talented people out there
and which are we'd be very happy to work
I'm sure okay let's talk about video
games video games Fire Emblem 8 this
came out no paper whole new show take a
live show we can just take a
back-to-back in my bed Fire Emblem fates
it's all next week comment is 19th June
I think of last year came out in Japan
yeah first of all how many [ __ ] games
is this because like it's three games
game three
explain to me why it's three games Alexa
well this was Peters okay so
well Peter decided it was gonna be three
separate reviews okay but so it's they
hired a television drama writer Shin
Kobayashi to write the story for this
game because people criticized awakening
story and we're like oh it's not that
good so this guy and intelligent systems
decided till I guess go overboard and
they made three separate stories and
made three separate games and they are
three separate stories with three very
different styles so it's not just a
story they actually played differently
as well they do yeah yeah it's I'd say
if you look at it from like a bird's eye
view it's like okay that looks the same
yeah but but functionally sort of you
know how you go about your journey and
you know this is a game or if you play
like I am there's permanent death and so
it's really important that your team is
strong and capable and it's it's tough
because in my version conquests that I'm
playing there's no option to grind for
experience or to then build
relationships and then make your party
work better together so I actually don't
have an opportunity to do that so I'm
just grinding like not grinding this out
the right word I'm beating my head
against a wall trying to beat these
missions with my team that's pretty
scrappy Alexa on the other hand has the
opportunity to scout I'm grinding in
both respects okay everyone's married
everyone has kids like I've got all the
kids everyone's really high-powered like
birthright gives you a lot more
resources and there's the scouting
feature which lets you randomly generate
an endless amount of optional
side-quests so you can just go and pound
out a few and either work on someone's
relationship or work on leveling someone
up okay so I've got a extremely large
team I think I have like 20 44 geez at
this point I think I'm down to like 16
people or so it's rude the third one
who's reviewing them what does that play
like I'm so I'm reviewing birth rate and
revelry okay okay and revelation so
birth right so the whole I mean they've
marketed this to death but the whole
thing is like you have to make a choice
you were raised by this family but you
find out you're not you're not part of
the noir Kingdom you were born in
hoshido okay no choices go to your birth
family or stick with your adopted family
right and birthrate is you go to your
birth family conquest is you stick with
your doctor okay revelation is join
misil you say no you say I will not
fight either of you okay
so neither side so when you start
neither side wants to help you so you
literally have like four units for like
five missions so to me and my best
friend and my butler and some other
person like going through whatever and
it's um a little bit of a mix of what
you're telling me about conquest and
birth right like all of my resources are
still available right and I can still
grind
however the map layouts are different
like there's a lot more manipulating of
the environment like you'll have to
you'll be on floating islands and have
to interact with portals that will put
you all over the place when maybe your
your team is split and you have to like
meet up or you have to catch an enemy
before they escape at a certain number
of turns so it's a sort of a mix between
the two but it's definitely a little bit
more like birthright in that I have
everything I need and everyone is happy
and married and has kids poor guy I made
the mistake of playing it on classic but
I will wait to describe why that was a
mistake for me personally can't talk
about it too much the embargo for the
reviews next week okay so but we'll get
into some of your thoughts on well I
hope you enjoying it a little bit we got
a bunch of questions from people so I
want to get to those first questions
from Jacob Weisner he asks how do you
feel about the weird ass face padding
mechanic being cut from the Western
release non-plus or relieved it's still
there it's still there there are there
are it's still there it's not totally
gone okay face patting so when you use
when you video games when you're in a
you can't do it to everyone I mean you
can do it to everyone do anything
everyone when you marry someone sure
it's like implied consent you can rub
their face yeah it's implied consent did
you wash your hands I'm sorry so like
pork so you you have like a like a
little like apartment that's yours and
you can invite people in one on one to
talk to you when you get married that
person is always there waiting for you
when you come home sure and as a slave
right and as you as you oh I married my
Butler so it's like really weird so like
the longer the more times you go in
there like every two missions or so
something new happens in your bond
deepens and new events will occur and
one of them is there sleeping and you
have to take the 3ds stylist and rub
their face until I wake up I actually if
you Jam the stylus down
hit them they'll wake up and be like
blah and they're like really unhappy
with you or you can be nice to them and
then there's another one where they have
just gotten out of the bath and the
prompt is blow gently and you have to
blow into the 3ds mic it's to watch like
remove the boss a blow stealer steam and
it's steam on the screen and the steam
just goes away it's like so I'm like
sitting like in my apartment like
frantically blowing on my 30s trying to
figure out like huh whatever so are they
more provocative in the Japanese release
or something or I I looked it up and
there's a couple of ones where like if
you're like touching your adopted no
you're touching your biological sibling
they'll be like what would mother think
or just like I love it when you put your
hands there oh I did some research it is
there the darknet the darknet but a lot
of that stuff is slowly that's airing it
comes out well so there's a there's a
thing where you invite people into your
house to hang out and that's where most
of the petting would have occurred is
when they come to visit it's very
obvious right now what you can do is
sort of just like look at their body
while they flirt with you which is
whatever you can like scan them from
like here okay yeah but like no feet
action no food no key though they have
feet this time they didn't have feet
before in awakening the character models
had no feet great films pretty much well
I don't necessarily know if I agree that
it was necessary to remove this stuff
yeah fire emblem like holes they're
mostly wholesale I can't I can't wrap my
head around getting upset about it
honestly it is it is such a minor facet
of the game at large that when people
are decrying like censorship and stuff
like that one they don't understand what
censorship is yeah
- it's like what do they get what are
they really getting upset like this
isn't the fight yeah like I mean there's
there's so much more to this game that
is so wonderful and if that's the one
thing you want to get upset about it to
the point that you're like essentially
calling out Nintendo and calling out
this game as like dude you're missing
the bigger picture and like entirely um
you know I get you one you know
everything that you were expecting right
but like is that that is a worth getting
that upset about can't we be happy that
we're actually getting this game and
that won't fire like like where's in
North America at least because a lot of
people are that you're right like at
least we're getting it because
like folks in Europe are freaking out
thinking they're not getting it for a
long time but but like but let's
celebrate the game because it is like a
wonderful game in many regards and this
one thing that is so inconsequential to
the larger picture we're gonna get upset
about that and make that the discussion
point yeah I don't get it I got more
questions here Edmund black asks in the
private quarters for Fire Emblem faith
is probably what we just talked about
there's mention of additional features
for spouses can you tell us what those
features are can i maybe some maybe
embargo ii it's not story related it's
not story related the games been on
japan for long okay alright so there's
the blowing that earlier
there's the petting and then if you get
up to a certain level you actually get a
special item that will that's only
available to you and your spouse that
like reduces the amount of damage you
both take when you're next to each other
in battles right just like actually a
really good prenuptial agreement it's
like a pretty cool item child i finished
yeah oh yeah and then you have old
they're not in the quarters but you can
also like have children and all the
children are actually pretty powerful
you can make the fight yes send them out
they become units and some of them come
out like fully formed ready to go
status maxed out like I have a I'm
playing in the end of birth right I had
a child army out on the field oh my god
I've got another question here question
tree no I don't re I don't know who said
this but it's a knife and awakening
rather easy is fates more difficult on
mechanically complex I believe is cuz
birth rate is like of course the
conquest is pretty hard you know as
always choosing between classic and
casual can dictate your experience but
there are difficulty settings as well so
if you're looking for a challenge you
can definitely find it I would assume in
both versions if you want to play
lunatic mode and go crazy now I mean I
think this game is is pretty hard anyway
on normal especially with classic where
perma death is a thing and because it's
you know random dice rolls for some of
the percentages for these things it's
easy to find your cell
confident and then cut down by just one
guy who like kills your main character
so cool I couldn't couldn't help it
revelations there a revelation it's like
the matrix I'm gonna keep saying wrong
revelations revelation that's it in
march the other two are out in February
and how are you enjoying them so far
which is like the one that's kind of do
you think is the best of the three maybe
mmm
I don't think we're allowed to really
yeah to clarify revelation will actually
be available on launch day for anyone
who got the special edition oh right
really which opens up a whole other
topic for this game whoa so that means
the special edition has all three
versions on one cartridge stored locally
how much is it
80 bucks but it's totally sold out
there's no way to buy it now as you go
on eBay and drop it so if you didn't get
that then you basically have to wait the
best part yes yeah and then what you
have to do is buy the second portion of
the game is DLC and then buy revelation
is DLC as well oh oh so you can't just
get revelation down on its own you have
to buy the second and then the third
part they they do that because revelry
revelations plot is something that's
hinted at in both conquest and birth
right right so like it doesn't I guess I
guess it would make more sense like I
play birth right first and things make
more sense to me but it's like it's like
a they don't want to like spoil things
like a revelation it will expose pretty
much everything I think I recall mice
might play through a let me give me the
option to choose revelation right away
yeah there's like a thing in the game
that's like spoilers for the other house
has launched in Japan though wasn't all
launched as one thing was it was it I
think it's a very similar story we
really did yeah they divvied it up or
they had one version that had all its
it's difficult to meet from my
perspective it seems kind of weird but
it's difficult for me to pass judgment
because I don't I'm not for any of the
franchise and I don't know the
intricacies of the three different games
does it seem does that seem reasonable
to you or does that seem kind of weird
the special edition thing is kind of
unfair I think like having the early
access to it well I think the fact that
it's so limited in quantity yeah whereas
if anyone wants to do it cuz look it's
convenient right like who wants to
download all that stuff have all that
space on your SD card when you could
just have it all in one cartridge
I think these each individual game is so
big on its own and the stories are very
different like just talking to alexa
about one character in her plot like
total
different outcome you know a totally
different place in the world
so it's interesting like on their own
like they're each worthwhile things that
I would say yeah like this is a good
full price game but the fact is is like
they all are like gonna be coming out at
the same time they're all available why
divvy it up like that I don't know but
worst of all why limit it to the special
edition are all versions yeah last
question I guess are all three views
going up at the same time they should be
yeah looking at next Wednesday yep
yeah and how much time have you put into
it so far I a lot I I think I'm on hour
15 and the second revelation okay now
and I went over 24 hours for the first
game and I did all like the sites the
sites stuff I'm like obsessed with
marrying all my characters and getting
their kids because their kids are so
powerful it is so easy no it's awful I'm
like I'm like I'm like in my house and
like my boyfriend's asleep and I'm in
the dark under the covers like just like
marry crazy andis from Salt Lake City he
knows all about that alright sometime
next week Wednesday at sometime in the
morning on Wednesday it's awesome thank
you so much folks
yep yeah but don't go just yet Oh
Pokemon almost 2020 yeah 20 years old
let's do it we're all old we're all
gonna die but in the meantime let's
enjoy Pokemon let's celebrate it in fact
I calling up there's a bunch of Pokemon
stuff hidden gamespot we're sort of
celebrating the anniversary that I'm
actually abs Elda as well within a week
of each other six days apart sold is the
21st and pokemons the 27th I think cool
so there's a bunch of stuff in the side
I wanted to do a little something about
Pokemon on the lobby today so since
we're gonna be celebrating Pokemon I
thought why don't we just kind of [ __ ]
on Pokemon living I talk about what the
worst Pokemon are mmm cuz there's some
pretty bad poem so I asked both of you
mm-hmm to tell me what your least
favorite Pokemon is Peter Brown we've
got your one up first I think what is
what is the worst Pokemon do you think
of the seven billion Pokemon than their
I am a very superficial person that
judge things based on their appearance
okay and mushara is the worst in that
context it looks like a fetus with
intestines leaking out of its forehead
oh god it does the top of its head his
eye is actually shut you see the other
side show with eyelashes above its rosy
cheek for the people listening on the
podcast this is really not gonna play
but don't worry that's okay that's
pretty bad yeah continue know that
that's pretty much it it looks awful
it's like the presidential debate
everyone gets through favorite pokemons
so I it's the stupid keyring one klefki
klefki this is something you find at the
bottom of your purse like whatever I I
don't know I Pokemon are supposed to be
organic right they set them up is like
these are creatures in the world and
you're white and you bottle them and
they do whatever what the hell is this
it is not hearings don't don't appear in
the wild neither do bags of trash or
what was that other one that's really
odd you want to see bag of trash I think
we owe the sword that we've trubbish
right there there there's trouble you
have garbodor no garbage is the is the
evolution right yeah it so much it's
like they ran out of animals to work
with or whatever yeah we've got more
we've got clink as well I think let's
just go through them and see what pops
up and see if I can remember okay
that's Smoochum I haven't seen half of
these because I gave up and pokemons
because of this yeah the guy the 120 was
pure now it's all going crazy that's
clink-clink is a bunch of gears so it's
multiple gears it's not a single gear no
it's two gears it's the oh that's a
slurpuff which I believe is episode made
them up come on yeah Chinpokomon yeah
lamda lamda on yeah okay this is the
best named one of all this one's called
love disk
fish now Lu V D is K love this Luvdisc
yeah I think we might have is that it is
out all of them I think that's all I saw
them say man
wink it turns out is a lot of shitty
[ __ ] there's a sword there's a sword
ownage no no let's describe oh let us
know in the comments folks oh that's
garbage or garbage oh there's my baby
boy he's like cement thank you so much
for coming in and I'm Pokemon with me
but we'll be celebrating Pokemon on
GameSpot calm and next week I think week
after lets out this next week I think
never sure nut stuff so a lot of cool
written features and videos on GameSpot
calm but let us know what Pokemon you
hatin the most in the comments below
an x-ray Korea thank you so much for
joining us you're gonna stick around for
a second yes we're gonna iron Sam
Snead's talk about titanfall thank well
led you back to reviewing 20 different
million types of fire related games Fire
Emblem oh my goodness
my god Aaron Thompson what's your least
favorite Pokemon kick your table don't
worry about it just don't hit the king
Pokemon this in that poker this is now
podcast about you know yeah
target they hated that last segment
because it was all the bad vegetables
all you just have to be very descriptive
we weren't we just laughed is that
Google yes that's crapping mushara my
Sharna sure I mean start there we go
always a favor we should put on the new
logo for the lobby that's that's a real
shame that's a real shame alright oh go
go for it no yeah no I liked it my
favorite Pokemon is the one where
they're gonna have you out in the world
and like fall off cliffs
I mean augmented reality like the first
time somebody falls off the Marin
Headlands like down some alleyway and is
some people buying drugs and whatever
you want me to be man
garbodor is that you it's like no it's a
real pilot rajashekhar is that you just
finding love it's about no way that's
gonna go wrong it's gonna be it's gonna
be like the Wiimote thing right yeah
it's gonna be people like getting hit in
the head and breaking their TVs right
through the TV yeah except they're just
like taking pictures of love Valentine's
Days if you love discs everywhere
hanging on out of [ __ ] shop windows
everything I didn't end oh we deserve
exactly
folks you've got any questions about
titanfall - in the campaign whether you
think it's a real good idea or not let
us know in the twitch comments gonna be
checking them out but first of all let's
talk about ourselves titanfall 2 at time
Falls sold over 10 million copies so I
guess the sequel was always on the cards
however there was this one sort of thing
that people thought about the first game
and they were like oh that doesn't have
a campaign it's the folks who made call
it Duty for about a warfare and a bunch
of other great games and but they did
have this thing called campaign
multiplayer which sort of replaced it
and got fed people into the multiplayer
part of the game so I guess there's kind
of this thing now last week or a couple
days ago and one of the guys at
titanfall said that the titanfall 2
whatever it's going to be called it's
going to have a traditional I guess
single-player campaign so I've asked
both you guys or got you both in here
it's kind of talked about whether or not
you think that's a good idea or what do
you think it's worthwhile or not I guess
first of all iron where do you sit on
this mmm I really appreciated that
titanfall tried something different I
really like the fact that they
integrated the two if they have the
multiplayer campaign I mean of course
you have problems when you have player
drop-off and people trying to finish the
campaign later on but get around but my
biggest problem with that was just they
didn't commit enough to it not that it
was there there were moments in that one
like there's a mission on the Odyssey
where this is like this derelict ship
we're like there's audio prompts talking
about trying to start the ship back up
but the players were never fighting in
the like engine room right or there was
one called three towers an airstrip
where they were talking about following
a blood trail but like you were never
following the blood trail yes like I
love the idea they just they just need
to commit to the idea more so that
players are doing the missions and then
there's like at least a binary ending
where there actually is the IMC win or
the militia wins because yes the way
that campaign ended was they were like
you guys want some we guys want some and
now let's go do multiplayer yeah yeah
see you in the next war Jesse Stern said
one of the shortcomings of the first
game was that we just did not have the
mechanism to tell everyone here here's
who you are here's where you are and
who's around you we knew all the answers
we just could not deliver on there was
the kind of smell of a really new game
there or a real new university you were
like part of but you like iron said you
kind of never really got into it that
much you think a campaign would fix that
or do you think they just kind of didn't
execute on the campaign multiplayer idea
well enough well I think the campaign
will inherently allow them to flesh out
the story and provide more context I
mean that's a no-brainer you know I
think it's a worthwhile effort because
it's it's a world that is somewhat
interesting that has you know humans
with abilities and robots that they can
interface with that it's not something
you see in a lot of games right so just
sort of describe the world around that
and present it in a way that makes it
even more interesting would be a good
move I think but what I'm more
interested in is rather than the online
multiplayer thing where they're talking
about the story so much it's using a
focused you know design campaign to
allow the mechanics to do some
interesting stuff that aren't possible
in multiplayer right we don't want to do
to use to do yeah like build levels
around the the mechanics that you have
your disposal to make some more
interesting gameplay than just this is
multiplayer that's addressed as you know
a story or even just a single-player
campaign that is like you against bots
in a similar map or even a similar setup
that you would face like do something
really cool that's different from
multiplayer that's not just telling a
tale one of the things that sort of
comes up whenever companies take on the
whole single-player thing is that
spending time on these like super
focused super like content heavy
development cycles for you know
single-player campaigns might take a
focus away from what otherwise would be
done on multiplayer do you think are
they need to do much more with the
multiplayer of this game because they
kind of seem like they crack the not
really well on the first time around
like how much different how much
different gameplay do you need a Oedipa
titanfall - it depends I don't know how
I can't speak tell Limited they are on
the technical side but I can think of
large enough time ahead of like there's
a lot that they could do with this game
in terms of when they release map packs
they you know the maps worth always
thematically connected
and things like actually having players
go seamlessly from one map to the next
map without a loading screen where you
play a series of maps that feed into
each other or things like doing PvE in
the PvP so there was a map called their
level call there be dragons whether
these giant dragons and when you shot
them they were just kind of like fly off
rather than aggro on characters so I
mean they could add PvE there's I think
that this guy is the limit on the
universe was incredible all of the maps
told the story and they could add
mechanics if they wanted to and if they
had the technical capabilities to do it
we got a bunch of feedback in on this
one Felipe and your ro Joe as puts a
question in here after something some
disappointments this Jen I don't buy
multiplayer only full-price games
anymore so this is totally worth it for
me and when it comes to the campaign in
fact I actually put out a little Twitter
poll I got about one and a half thousand
votes 64% people said they were more
likely to buy it if it had a campaign
with 34% basically saying it didn't
really matter to them either way that's
kind of the thing right is that like
some people will play a campaign but we
always hear anecdotally when it comes to
games like Call of Duty some people just
don't care so it's weird it's like you
brought the split where some people will
love a campaign and won't where they're
kind of done with multiplayer only games
and then there's other people who are
like they just they think it's a waste
of money
basically because I'm never gonna spend
time on it people consider every game
for many different reasons sometimes
it's brand times they want to get Call
of Duty because them and their friends
always get the new Call of Duty and
they're zombies
Mattin and Madden FIFA the same way you
know and but at the same time if someone
just wants a competitive experience
these days there are so many free to
play competitive shooters mmm that it's
like do I need to drop 60 bucks just for
that I feel like for a lot of people
it's got to be a really compelling game
that has something really different like
titanfall did yeah but now the titanfall
has come out and we've seen that they're
gonna come back again in charge full
price I think they have to do the
campaign your massive final Rainbow six
seeds you've been playing a lot of a
recently that's a game that's
multiplayer only has that the soured at
all it has a situation's mode but you
know I have a hard time understanding
how I think single-player campaigns sell
games and I think they look pretty they
can make them look pretty they look
right in advertisements yes and I'm not
gonna discount they're people who
genuinely love single-player games but
if you look at the amount of time that
you're gonna
in a single-player game on in a shooter
not like an RPG you're gonna spend let's
let's just say like maximum 12 hours in
the average game like 8 to 12 hours okay
this is an Infinity Ward thing you could
probably you know it would be fair to
say it's already gonna be around 5 or 6
right you can easily spend a hundred
hours
that's not exaggeration and some people
spend upwards of 200 hours in
multiplayer so if you're a developer and
you're looking at the budget that it
costs to put in a single-player campaign
versus you know the people who are gonna
spend 100 or 200 hours in your game I
find it hard to justify multiplayer
shooters wasting such a large portion of
their budget when they can just do twice
the maps or put it into some fantastic
destruction technology or you know just
better-looking gamer but if you look at
the the numbers on this poll I think
that's a pretty good indication that the
majority of people don't care so much
that the campaigns are short and that
they're gonna get more value if they
just play multiplayer a lot I think it's
a certain type of person that really
just wants to do the multiplayer thing
and then there was like there was you
know 34 percent said they didn't care
either way so you could take that eyes
I enjoyed the multiplayer a lot or you
could take the other way and say I don't
care about single-player like it doesn't
make a difference to me either way so
yeah it's really strange I wonder if the
fact that as well I did say when I said
Infinity Ward I meant the people who
made those old infinity war games of
course is obviously respawn
Entertainment's and that his new thing
and but I wonder if the fact that this
game sold 2 million copies and it was an
xbox one exclusive and now they're
making a game it's gotta come out on PC
and PlayStation 4 as well as well as the
Xbox one like I wonder if that's the
like if they have a little bit more
leeway you know financially to sort of
make it happen and that maybe this is
there like a big play to take a Call of
Duty right like I bet those guys would
love nothing more than to take over Call
of Duty's like the user market base or
whatever and I guess you're never going
to do it unless you have a campaign
right it's like you gotta take that box
for some people and they I mean I'm not
saying that they couldn't do a really
good campaign in this world again their
map design for multiplayer we're all
fully fleshed out worlds like you could
walk around the map and you'd be like
well this is where the ships land here's
the passport office like here's where
people live I mean it was so clear when
you play those maps of that somebody
actually sat down in a road
story and then made the map as opposed
to vice versa so you know I think it's
as they said I think they knew what the
world was and they may not have had the
budget to do the campaign because again
like I thought I saw an article recently
they were saying as much as 75% of their
budget am I going to single
single-player campaign so it makes sense
if you're just trying to deliver this
multiplayer shooter to compete with call
of duty that you just spend the money on
multiplayer and then if you sell it 10
million copies hey we got the money now
let's make a campaign I should mention
as well as about Mexico point and the
twit shot this game actually did comment
on PC last time around at times I should
yeah that's true and it came out in the
Xbox 360 as well Oh AJ attitude was an
awesome port blue point productions yeah
cuz they did the part for that they did
the part for gravity rush remastered oh
really then no your solid HD collection
they are one of the best studios out
there that most people don't know on top
of their master Porter's that's
excellent a bunch of people in the child
is well asking I mean the multiplayer
sort of online shooter world has changed
a little bit a lot more
microtransactions now sort of par for
the course titanfall it seemed to stay
away from that for the most part they
had a season pass with some maps and
stuff and what do you think about that
do you think they'll dive into that we
spawn seemed to be a team were really
sort of they care about what their
community thinks about them when it
comes to my corrosion when it comes to
microtransactions if you make people
care about your game they'll want to
spend money and I think developers
deserve to make money on the games that
they release I mean the price of a game
has been what $60 for decade now and I
think a lot of the reasons why you're
seeing crazy stuff like premium and you
know battlefront launching with forcing
it your Maps per mode I think their
budgets are getting cut down by the fact
that they're still selling games for $60
and so I think at this point developers
are either gonna have to raise the price
of games do things like premium or do
micro transactions it doesn't seem like
just the what I gather from talking to
developers it just doesn't seem like the
$60 game is gonna cover their cost
anymore
yeah so to me micro transactions are the
lesser evil if they're done right if
they're not cutting out contents and
making you feel like you're not getting
a good deal if they're making you love
the game and then they're giving you
things that you
want to buy because you love the game
just as long as they're not you know
yeah taking away some of the the
fairness in it like I remember the burn
cards they had in the first game if you
could suddenly like just acquire a bunch
of those FIFA style yeah I guess we'll
find out it depends
most of the a lot of games have just
gotten vanity with yeah with it I mean
like the debate is that this morning a
fact is gonna be a stream on right after
this live show and which RK is gonna be
playing the game they've got a bunch of
new skins and whatnot I'm sure they're
gonna start selling those bad boys do
there's egregious breaches that though
like a you know you're Battlefront they
saw the deal 44 blasters Han Solo's
blaster for $10 extra and it was it was
the highest level unlock in the game and
ended up being the opie pistol that
everybody hated oh really so like that
was just totally egregious that was just
there yeah yeah like just throw grenade
and close the door kind of last DLC move
so I get why people are apprehensive
when you know yeah like your
transactions get kicked around ya can't
trust them apart from that though last
thoughts on this excited for time fall
to tooten fall yeah
respawn Entertainment's is one of the
few developers that i've spoken with in
previews right where a lot of developers
give you their BS marketing push and you
don't believe them you learn not to
believe them these guys I thought that
they were biessing me and then they
delivered this like 5 or 6 v6 combat
that I thought you couldn't do with
mechs and they had great mechanics like
ejecting just to give you more time to
play the game a lot of the things that I
thought they were biessing me on I was
totally wrong like they were absolutely
right and they knew what they were doing
so I'm excited to be proven wrong if I'm
doubtful of this game again if if that
happens again I will be very excited
yeah that'd be awesome
Peter what about yourself I'm very much
excited titanfall was one of the best
shooters for me in probably a decade or
more
I love the the new things they did and I
can't wait to see what else they have up
their sleeve I really want there to be
new Titans that do some ridiculous [ __ ]
and I'll be really happy it was a game
that sort of I guess it was one of the
early games that came out on that next
generation of consoles the current gen
now it felt like it was like 80% of the
way of being something something super
super special oh yeah yeah cuz it was
really special but it was like never
like sucker punch just never came I
think it's and I hate to say the
campaign is the most important thing
because I don't think it is but when you
really want to identify with a world
like you got a struggle you got a
succeed you have to let go through you
know what it means to be a person in
that world not just have someone in your
ear telling you hey I just want to
convince you that you're really here and
that you're a part of this [ __ ] like you
have to live and breathe it and do it
and so yeah that that should be really
cool they can pull that off Coby could
go either way you never know like some
games you play a lot of multiplayer some
games you just played a campaign like I
looked at call of duty and I don't even
ever played a multi pair another good
kill zone and I won't even played as
well see where this one lands let us
know what you think if you're excited
about the new titanfall game whatever
it's going to be called please call it -
in the fall and let us know in the
comments below and that's a show man I
went by favors ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much you already here flex
payments oh that's opposed don't worry
about that's why right touch your beard
that time mmm it was great forget see
that's why it's all good thank you so
much to everyone who watched the show
thank you so much to everyone who
supported the show over the past couple
years and especially over the past month
where we sort of shopped around and got
this all done and we are going to be
here every Tuesday 2:00 p.m. Pacific so
make sure you stay there you go three
cameras have to figure out which one of
us and make sure you you put us in your
calendar if you don't you can always
catch us on gamespot comm or youtube and
of course if you like the listening to
us in your earholes describing pokemon
make sure you hop on your RSS feed i'll
tweet it out if not at the end of today
then at some stage tomorrow and you can
subscribe to the show on there as well I
wanna give a special shout out to the
awesome production crew who put this
thing together especially mr. Andy
bellman on behind the camera look at
sweeten his rocket League shirt Josh
Shaw on the back Eric Tay and gaarkhan
order me who did all the amazing
graphics as well thanks everyone as well
for putting this set together it's super
cool we're gonna be using it for loads
of stuff here not just this show at the
table we got all this stuff in the
background the SS Pikmin will float
again yeah we're gonna do a live
community show as well every week so
just want to get rid of a sail boat that
was that his desk any like exactly like
the desks are not big they're not big at
all so he's now used to do twice as much
work that's what yesterday and thanks so
much for watching the show we'll be back
next week Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific
thanks again let us know your thoughts
about the show in the comments below we
will see you then adios